soweit unsere live berichterstattung von
der pressekonferenz aus kaiserslautern
zum polizistenmord in kusel in der nacht
auf den montag war dass zwei polizisten
wurden während ihrer arbeit getötet in
mainz bin ich jetzt verbunden mit thomas
mayer ist von der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft der
landesvorsitzende in rheinland-pfalz ich
grüße sie herr
meier sie haben eben die pressekonferenz
ebenso aufmerksamen wie wir hier
mitverfolgt was sind ihre eindrücke
ja das ist eine gute frage
ich bin an der stelle einem der
staatsanwälte dankbar hinsichtlich der
aussage
welche vorstellungen wir als
gesellschaft von so einem vorgehen haben
das ist unfassbar und ich bin immer noch
schockiert und deswegen wird das was in
der pressekonferenz so sachlich und auch
richtig dargestellt wird diesen
tragischen
fall leider ein stückweit nicht gerecht
mit geschrieben was der staatsanwalt
sagte wir haben bei uns in deutschland
von seiten der polizisten eine kultur
der vernunft kultur der höflichkeiten
dagegen steht der blinder hass der
manchmal entgegen schließt und das eher
ein gesellschaftliches problem nicht
ursächlich von der polizei ausgegangen
also sondern ursächlich in der
gesellschaft dieser blinder hass merken
sie dass in der polizeiarbeit diese
gespiegelt bekommen dass diese hat sich
wirklich verstärkt hat
in der tat
aktuell ist es so wir sind natürlich
auch als berufsvertretung und als
deutsche polizeigewerkschaft in sozialen
netzwerken unterwegs und haben leider
auch dort feststellen müssen wie sie
wahrscheinlich auch selbst festgestellt
haben welche kommentare dort im netz
unterwegs sind und wenn man sich
vorstellt wie dynamisch das ganze ist
und sich dort leute entsprechend äußern
und fast schon hier ruhig diese dieses
tötungsdelikt darstellen dann macht es
mich mehr als nachdenklich und dort sind
wir alle gefordert politik gesellschaft
dort ein klares zeichen dagegen zu
setzen und mit entsprechenden möglichen
maßnahmen dort gegen anzugehen
oder wie beurteilen sie denn die
ermittlungen bis jetzt ist war ja ein
schneller fahndungserfolg damit konnte
man natürlich nicht rechnen aber ich
frage nach den hintergründen die
zusammenarbeit bund länder polizei
politik öffentlichkeit
es ist angekommen in der pressekonferenz
die gute zusammenarbeit in dem fall dem
polizeipräsidium westpfalz und den
kollegen des saarlandes allein auch von
der nähe und das ist gelebte praxis
unabhängig von der papier lage dass man
sich dort sehr gut und sehr schnell
unterstützt und bedenken sie wir haben
auch einander falls die situation dass
wir gut aufgestellt sind was
beispielsweise die spezial spezialkräfte
in dem fall das sek betrifft die sind
disloziert aufgestellt in der nähe von
kaiserslautern und kommt natürlich auch
dort schnell gerufen werden und dann
entsprechend auch die objekte im prinzip
in den angriff nehmen wie sehen sie denn
jetzt den ausblick auch für sich als
polizisten dieser beruf auch wenn es
fast unangenehmen erscheint an einem
solchen tag die frage zu stellen muss ja
attraktiv bleiben damit ein rechtsstaat
ein rechtsstaat bleiben kann wie sichern
sie das für die zukunft wie kann dieser
beruf trotz dieser barbarischen gewalt
vorgestern weiterhin attraktiv bleiben
es fällt mir natürlich schwer und der
stelle mit dem begriff attraktivität
jetzt umzugehen in dieser stunde in
diesen minuten nach so einer
schrecklichen tat
es ist natürlich für jeden unserer
kolleginnen und kollegen der sogenannte
reale albtraum der dort dann ja sich
einstellt wenn man opfer einer solchen
tat wird ich erinnere mich an der stelle
gerne sehr ungerne zurück das jahr 2000
dort wurden acht polizisten im
bundesgebiet unter anderem auch im
nachgang festzustellen im zusammenhang
mit der nsu affäre auch bei solchen
einfachen
banalen erscheinenden kontrollen getötet
aber das hier und jetzt eine ganz andere
qualität und insofern müssen wir
natürlich überlegen wie wir auf so etwas
reagieren und das machen wir
selbstredend nach jedem 1 egal wir
ausgegangen ist ab so tragisch und
tödlich wie in diesem fall wird man auch
dort seine lehren daraus ziehen und die
kollegen sind natürlich sehr betroffen
nichtsdestotrotz sind wir als polizisten
auch ein stück weit so geerdet dass wir
wissen dass wir uns tagtäglich
insbesondere die kollegen die auf der
straße unterwegs sind in eine gewisse
gefahr in eine gewisse latente gefahr
begeben und mit diesem umstand lernen
wir auch umzugehen wir sind sehr gut
ausgebildet wir haben ich habe gestern
noch mit einer studentin gesprochen die
mir davon berichtet hat was nach dieser
schrecklichen tat an der hochschule der
polizei in rheinland-pfalz sofort
gemacht worden ist die kollegin boden
zusammengerufen es gab eine gemeinsame
trauerfeier ist wurde aufgearbeitet und
natürlich soziale betroffen aber es sind
auch in dem bewusstsein dass sie sehr
gut ausgebildet sind das ist mehr von
ihr bestätigt worden und das auch die
kollegen draußen ist es angeklungen wie
so eine auszubildende auch integriert
wird im rahmen der ausbildung in welcher
phase sie dort sich befindet und wie sie
dort eingesetzt wird dort sind wir sehr
gut aufgestellt und am ende bleibt
leider nur das fazit an der stelle es
gibt weder für uns als polizei auch
unter den bürger keine 100 prozentige
sicherheit und mit diesem bewusstsein
geben natürlich tagtäglich in unseren
dienst ganz herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch thomas mayer war das von der
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft er ist
landesvorsitzender in rheinland pfalz
dankeschön sehr gerne